وقد اعتقلت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي 32
فلسطينيا على الاقل خلال الليله الماضيه
في عموم انحاء الضفه الغربيه وفاد نادي
الاسير الفلسطيني في بيان بان عمليات
الاعتقال تركزت في بلده قطنه شمال غربي
القدس حيث اعتقلت قوات الاحتلال 12 مواطنا
على الاقل
فرجت لاحقا عن مجموعه منهم بينهم سيده
اخذتها رهينه خلال عمليات تحقيق ميدانيه
اجرتها اثناء اقتحامها هذ البلده واضاف ان
شرطه الاحتلال دهمت حي جبل المكبر في
القدس واعتقلت والده الشهيد احمد عليان
منفذ عمليه الطعن قرب حاجز مزموريه بين
القدس وبيت لحم مساء الخميس الماضي وتابع
نادي الاسير ان قوات الاحتلال اعتقلت ايضا
مواطنين من نابلس والخليل وبيت لحم وطول
كرم ورام الله واشار نادي الاسير في بيانه
الى ان العدد الاجمالي للمعتقلين منذ
السابع من شهر اكتوبر من العام الماضي
ارتفع الى
4910 معنا من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره
وليد العمري اذا الاف من المعتقلين وبشكل
يومي اذا في محافظات عده التي تشهد
اقتحامات وهنا نذكر بمطالبه حركه حماس
الصليب الاحمر والمؤسسات الحقوقيه بتحمل
المسؤوليه تجاه ما تتعرض له تحديدا فئه
الاسيرات داخل السجون المعلوم عن الظروف
التي يعيشها الاسرى والاسيرات وليد بهذا
العدد الكبير داخل
السجون اولا قريه قطنا غربي القدس هي اخر
القرى التي تعرضت للاقتحامات الليله
الماضيه وفجر اليوم حيث دهمت قوات كبيره
واعتقلت 12 من مواطنيها وبذلك ارتفع الى
32 مجمل ما اعتقلته قوات الاحتلال خلال
الليله الماضيه وفجر اليوم واصبح مجموع
المعتقلين منذ بدايه الحرب على غزه التي
دخلت يومها ال7
4910 وفق نادي الاسير الفلسطيني سلطات
الاحتلال تلاحق ايضا ذوي الكثير من
المقاومين سواء نفذوا عمليات ام لا وامن
تعتبرهم بالمطلوبين داخل السجون
الاسرائيليه ال 24 كان بالاضافه لهذا
العدد هناك نحو
5300 من الاسرى المحكومين وايضا منص
الاسرى الذين حكم عليهم بالاعتقالات
الاداريه دون ادانه او دون ايه عمليه
تقديم لوائح الظروف الاسرى هي سيئه طيله
الوقت لكنها زادت سوءا بعد ان تولى ايتمار
بن كفير حقيبه الامن القومي وذهب الى درجه
انه رفض
تمديد
ولايه ولايه المسؤوله عن السجون بذيع انها
لا تلبي ولا تنفذ مطالبه حيث وضع اجنده
للانتقام من الاسرى والاسيرات الفلسطينيين
على نحو واسع الان حسب اخر الارقام او
الاحصائيات الوارده من سلطه السجون فان
نسبه الكثافه داخل هذه السجون تفوق 95%
وهذا يشير الى الازمه في داخلها كما انهم
ذهبوا الى محاولات عزلهم والقيام بعمليات
نقل لهم وحرمانهم من الخبز اليومي الطازج
ومن الحمام اليومي او توفر المياه وتعرضوا
كثيرا لعمليات تعذيب كان واضح منها ان
هدفها الانتقام هذا يشمل الاسيرات في سجن
الدامون في منطقه جنوب بحيفا ويشمل جميع
الاسرى الفلسطينيين في كافه السجون سواء
كانت تابعه لسلطه مصلحه السجون او لجيش
الاحتلال هذه الكثافه والسياسه التي وضعها
بن كبير منذ ان تولى هذه الحقيبه قبل عام
بالضبط تعرض حياه الاسرى وهذا ما حذر منه
ايضا نادي الاسير الفلسطيني وهيئه شؤون
الاسرى وكافه المؤسسات التي تعنى بشؤون
الاسرى والاسيرات
الفلسطينيين حيث ذه للانتقام منهم باتخاذ
اجراءات انتقاميه لحرمانهم حتى من ابسط
الحقوق التي تتوفر ل للاسرى في كافه انحاء
العالم وهنا يشار الى ان هؤلاء الاسرى
الامنيون الفلسطينيون هم اسرى معظمهم
محكوم عليهم وبينهم اسرى وازن من اصحاب
المحكومية قضيه ت تعنى وتحظى باهتمام واسع
وما جاء بطلب حركه حماس وايضا ما تطالب به
كافه الجهات الفلسطينيه من ان يكون هناك
متابعه من قبل الصليب الاحمر والهيئات
الدوليه لوضعهم لانه كما معلوم خلال هذه
الحرب هناك سته اسرى قتلوا داخل السجون او
فقدوا حياتهم جراء التعذيب حسب نادي
الاسير وهو ما يشير الى ما يتعرض له من
استهداف والى ان عددهم داخل السجون قد
تقريبا تضاعف وليد العمري مدير مكتب
الجزيره من رام الله شكرا جزيلا